welcome back everybody to the final
moments of round three here in Bucharest
Romania one very important game has just
finished that is the game between janepo
miyashi and our world champion dingley
rending welcome back to the show this
was a difficult game and everybody's
eyes was on this game yeah
how did you feel about the opening he
surprised you at the first move he
played D4 he played only E4 during the
world championship match did you expect
this at all uh not today but I had
prepared D4 during the World
Championship after he first imported it
in round three so actually I prepared
this line but today I I forgot the the
moves yup yup and let's go through the
game in fact take take E3 and you play
this move Bishop two F5 exactly what I
prepared
foreign
remember if I was also good
and this idea with Knight F3 is magnus's
idea right with yes okay also play nine
times white pieces before so you knew
the ins and outs of this uh particular
yeah opening
let's go A5
and this is the first moment I think you
started thinking
A4 and now Knight to D7 F4 yeah this is
a critical moment after Knight B1 it's
become very bad already
um
C1 and Knight to B1
how are you feeling at this point I mean
there was so much pressure right now
Knight to B1 he was playing more or less
fast it felt like he knew what he's
doing
how are you feeling about first my
thought was after he played F4 well if
three promise became weak
although I had a double double combat
heat pump also very weak so
yes yeah I might have some counter play
on queen size by Bishop C2 to place a
bishop to be through him but then after
midnight B1 suddenly the night the
bishop is under attack yes did you miss
this move Knight to B1 yeah yeah before
you played Bishop C2 right yeah
and then you played you found this very
interesting idea what is the plan here
535 immediately to press default product
the bishop he had Bishop B5 and uk5963
okay five and Knight to C3 right now
that makes a lot of sense okay because
we were thinking something on the fifth
rank after you played it okay five
against Knight to F5 and then take and
then some D4 ideas later on in the game
we weren't sure why you played this move
route to A5 so thank you for clarifying
that
um and he played Bishop E2
C5
you're seeing the evaluation yeah
which here he can also play 92 yeah
is this what you're calculating yeah
yeah this one is
is difficult okay you still have some
opposite color Bishops but Knight to F5
you cannot move the
yeah yeah difficult difficult situation
but you fought on yeah and he played
this move Bishop to E2 were you feeling
that he's maybe misstepping at this
point
with his last few moves yeah he must
Miss Knight
I thought my position quite bad but I
don't know how bad it is
and of course you don't have the
computer next to you during the game
right so he didn't know how good it is
either right and once you play this move
Knight away did you feel like you're
getting
enough initially into the game after 98
since I have very clear plan 97 P5
before and
cannot play Bishop X3 you cannot stop
and prevent B5 I can play B5 anyway if
we take take and then before practice be
better and now the Rook on A5 yeah
yeah very nice
okay and
he did Knight C3 Knight C7
King to F2 he played before I have to
stay on my plan stay with your plan yeah
before 33 here
yeah it's nice Bishop C4 I have Bishop
D2 if
Knight E3 and Bishop D2 are root create
in Bishop D2
takes
I'll be shooting for
and the King just you don't have room
yeah coming on B8 or eight
yeah
so you play The Rook to D5
oh boss
here Rook
um for 93. Rook B2
Behind These
so you should take Rook takes D5 now and
there's no Knight P6 Maybe
two
uh at all if you take with the bishop on
C4 here right after rooftop yeah yeah
so this was a good move but you played
Rook takes D5
at the same time at this point and maybe
this was the last moment for him uh to
play the move G for a solidify cement
this Knight of Empire I saw G4 here were
you worried about it
time I'm going pretty safe accessory C3
in night so good place on F5 yeah how
did you assess this position
did you think you're yeah I think I was
worried about you for yeah yeah this
turns out to be quite bad yeah yeah
but it's not that easy right and maybe
bishop to D2 here is also an idea
yeah yeah
but one thing and he did that during the
world championship match occasionally he
played very fast at the critical moments
and this is what he did as well
uh were you happy when you saw this move
Bishop takes C4 on the board yeah I'm
quite happy
uh because I
oh I calculate it until if we take on A4
I have this bishop D2 Check Yes it's
pretty nice if I yeah pretty nice chick
you cannot go King D3 because the rule
can take anything for you that's very
nice pretty good and this one probably
is just going to be I mean you still
have to defend it but it's most likely
going to be a car with a precise play
it's quite easy to draw
yeah and he played The Rook C4 and still
it wasn't easy even here right
Rook 31 and perhaps this was the last
moment he played this small group to B4
Rook to D1 which to my eyes looks very
artificial right and it just doesn't
make a lot of sense oh well I did not
consistency
and then he can take the pump so if you
continue King six three or two and then
but still you have your counter play
even here yeah
I can create some counter plane at least
yes yes not so easy to win not so easy
no no no my play quite quite clear just
to push the Palm on the king sides
some uh
very wise man once said that all the gun
games are drawn maybe he was right right
in this end game his pong over very not
it doesn't have any connect pump yeah
yeah no very nice
um then a good save for you definitely
how is how are your energy levels
right now quite low but during the game
I thought
why he played this 9p1
I feel
very tired yeah for this tournament it
actually began at first I didn't want to
participate because I'm so tired after
watching but now I'm
just trying to to hold try to
to continue to to play you've showed
your resilience time and time again uh I
think uh congratulations on a good save
and we're looking forward to see you in
the next few rounds and right now we
have one game pending the big clash
between Duda and Dak we're going to go
on a short break and we'll be back soon
foreign